[Music]
let's go out to Orlando Florida and talk
to Lance in the pants what's up
Lance hey how's it going good man what's
up not much that's literally the first
time I've heard Lance in the pants Oh I
had a buddy named Lance I called him
Lance in the pants for like 20 years it
literally just came out like I think
it's a part of my nervous system now so
Lance in the pants what's up I've heard
it a million times yeah um
so yeah I guess um I guess I'll just
start with kind of the question I gave
you um and probably work backwards from
there um basically just wanting to know
like when I should kind of throw in the
towel with with my marriage um it's just
been uh you know a lot of years of
struggles
and yelling and fighting
and smashing things so you I'm just
trying
to uh mostly me okay um at least when it
comes to the the the breaking things um
that absolutely has listen has nothing
to do with your
marriage zero no I I I understand that
it's something I've been working on for
a while okay um and that's kind of one
of the one of the problems I feel
like my marriage my wife specifically is
a trigger for that it's uh bull crap
dude I don't I don't buy it I don't buy
it she might know how to push your
buttons but every time you smash
something every time you yell that's the
choice you're making or if you can't
make it in that moment you've made the
choice to create a world where y'all
don't talk you don't connect you don't
exercise your body doesn't feel good
you're not sleeping you don't have a job
that you care to be at that where you
feel like you got a purpose and then all
that crap comes home all of those are
choices along on the way right right
yeah absolutely I I take full
responsibility for for that okay um like
you said she knows how to push my
buttons and I feel like she does it a
lot um and I've spent probably the last
four or five years tell her you know I
need connection I need when we talk I
need you to stay calm and not get ramped
up um and that part of it hasn't changed
so I'm just that's kind of where I'm at
with you know when do I say this isn't
going to change and I need to move on
the The Challenge here is by the way you
you quit your marriage whenever you want
to quit I don't think this is a marriage
that is unsalvageable I'll ask you a few
questions in a minute and you you can
just kind of cut to the chase for us all
but um yeah it's tough when you're
somebody who reacts in what I'm going to
I'm going to overuse a word right and so
I'm going to over dramatize this but not
really when you react in a violent way
meaning screaming using your body you're
you're bigger than she is is my guess
you're or maybe taller than you smash
stuff you get so angry and then you feel
shamed about it you get you get you're
like I'm never going to do that again
I'm going to be cool and then you come
to her and say hey when I talk to you I
need you to be calm I need you to be
cool so that we can have these
discussions and her nervous system
system knows no way in hell am I not
going to be fully on guard because who
knows what that dude's going to
do right and then that sets her she's
completely on edge you feel her being on
edge you start to get more and more
frustrated she feels it even more and so
what she do she hits you first to create
some space and then you go off and
hitting you first means she pushes your
buttons yeah and so the only way forward
is is there has to be a complete this
thing's got to to let me say this the
marriage you had is over the choice you
have is to rebuild one where you're both
in on it and you're going to have to do
more than four years of quote unquote
just working on it you're gonna have to
do better than that man and she's going
to have to
decide terrifyingly
so to put herself in a position to have
something smashed over her again to be
screamed at you have you all have little
kids yeah we have two little kids and
that's my biggest concerned because the
stuff has happened right in front of
them yeah but man you you you say in one
sentence like I totally own this but on
the other side you're like yeah this
kind of stuff just keeps happening in
front of them it's you you're happening
I mean yeah I don't mean it keeps it it
has happened and I don't want it to
happen anymore it's okay so tell me tell
me what happens in those moments where
you can't control
yourself
um cuz she's not on the phone with with
me hey and before we go I'm I'm I'm hard
put on you she's not on the phone and
dude I know I've got people in my life
that can just cut me to the
quick they know how to do that right
people I've been in relationship with
for years and years and years and years
in years men and women they can just say
the thing that sends me over the
edge and I know that so I've got some
choices I'll give you the most recent
scenario because that's what kind of
triggered me to call you okay um we were
you know we we're outside we had a
campfire uh out in our backyard it was a
great night you know made s'mores and
all that stuff there was a few moments
throughout the night where like one of
our sons was rolling around on the
ground and my wife was like don't roll
on the ground there's dog poop or
something like that and I was like just
let him roll the ground it's okay you
know let him be a kid and then another
one came up to us and asked for another
s'more and my wife is like No And I was
like just let him have one it's you know
we're having fun just you know Let it go
go so she was like she was saying she
was surprised by me being kind of loose
about things which I do tend to be very
tight you know when we're in everyday
stuff I like to keep a regular schedule
it keeps keeping a schedule keeps me on
track as
well um so when the night was over I was
cleaning up stuff outside she went
inside with the kids and I could hear
yelling from outside the house um I
don't remember exactly what happened but
I came inside and my wife is like I'm
losing my cool I need you to take over I
was like fine I'll take over no problem
and then my little one is like starts to
turn the TV on and I'm like I'm like no
it's 10:30 you know we'll go read a book
we're not going to watch TV she came
back out and was like why can't he watch
TV he's just he's got to calm his brain
and I'm like I don't want him to watch
TV it's it's 10:30 and then she like
kind of threw in my face that you know
you've been so loose all night long and
now this and we went back and forth and
it ended up with me getting angry and
breaking a
chair
um but it's those kinds of things it's
like this battle between us with control
I think well let's let's reverse
engineer this because it's deeper than
control we're going to go backwards
never freaking break anything in your
home again got it agreed cool are we
done with that crap cuz that's you
acting like a 5-year-old 5-year-old
smash
stuff yeah adults do not are you done
with
that I am yeah I want to be no bull crap
stop walk out the door go get a hotel
don't smash stuff in your
house you're encoding that stuff in your
kid's nervous system
quit you're terrifying your wife
stop and then going back times where
I've I've done the walking out the door
and you know I would say I gotta leave
I'll be back and then when I get back I
get guilted by my wife for leaving and
the kids were upset about me leaving and
I'm like well it's one or the other like
either you're exactly right it's one or
the other I know when I've exceeded my
capacity to act like an adult I'm going
to step out for a
minute and for the first two three five
10 times your kids are going to be where
did daddyy go is he coming back and
Mom's going to act like irrational and
be mad and yelling but you're going to
be practicing staying calm in a
moment yeah right the adult is running
the house not the child so the the
description you described to me sounds
like dude chill out they're at a fire
he's rolling around the yard so what if
he gets dog poo that's how he's gonna
learn what I heard yeah
is a woman who is constantly trying to
please her husband who's got a bunch of
rules and schedules and
regulations and she so here's what she's
trying to do a trying to keep the peace
to trying to keep this crazed man calm
and B in her own weird way she's trying
to love you the best you
can and then you switch it and my guess
is that goes against her nature and so
she feels like she's always having to be
the mean
parent and then suddenly in front of the
kids she's the super mean parent and you
become the cool
parent and then there's another instance
where there's a TV on at 10:30 at night
with a little kid which by the way that
does not calm down any child's brain it
spins it up but then suddenly she's like
oh I want to be the cool parent which is
is that is that an like an like a
childish response yes is that
understandable of
course and here's the deeper problem
y'all haven't had those talks before
they happen you'll haven't had like hey
what are we how's our parenting approach
going to be to screen
time how's our parenting approach going
to be to X and Y and Z because my guess
is you said uh keeping a schedule keeps
you on track I don't buy that I think
keeping a schedule keeps you in control
I bet your schedule's pretty rigorous
huh uh it's it's a little crazy yeah
okay so mine is
too but my wife gets up at a different
time than me and my wife actually gets
up and writes for an hour and has a cup
of coffee and she has like a little like
a muffiny cookie thing something I I
usually don't ever eat in the morning we
have very different morning
routines why do you subject your family
to
yours I don't I don't try to subject my
family to mine I I'm up at 5: in the
morning I go work out you know and my
wife isn't usually up until around 7 7
30 and she gets our kids ready for
school then I take our younger one to
school um and that part is all fine with
me
that part of the problem I have with it
is it's not with her it's not consistent
so it's like there'll be times I come in
for at 7 o'clock and she slept through
like three alarm clocks and you know
it's 20 after and I'm having to wake her
up and say hey I'm going to be late
getting our son school I need you to get
up so a lot of it feels like parenting
her sometimes and I I get frustrated
that one thing I told her a couple
months back when we were talking is I
feel like I've been pushing our family
up a hill for the last 10 years and it's
just I'm getting worn
out because I'm constantly trying to
push to
keep things moving forward
you ever asked your wife what she
wanted I mean we sat down and we've had
talks with like she'll tell me I need I
need um I need romance I need you know
in Romance to hers like little notes
here and there or bringing her flowers
and um you know I've done those things
not consistently to my you know if I'm
being honest I'm not real consistent
about it because again our schedule gets
crazy and I just
forget um but it should be you know I've
like started in the last couple months
putting notes in my calendar to remind
me you know on Thursdays pick up flowers
or you know stuff like
that um so we've sat down and had the
talks about needs and you know wants and
stuff like
that
I I've told her many times I need
connection from her and connection for
me is like long deep conversations and
she's just like well I I'm not smart
about those things I can't have those
deep conversations I'm like I just want
to talk I want someone that I can talk
and laugh and have fun with um are you
somebody that every that every
conversation ends up like in
some like a huberman
podcast or every or every conversation
ends up in a Dr AA podcast
I'm I'm a lot like that I'll admit it so
here deep thinker so I almost burned out
every friend I have over that
crap so two things number one I have a
coach that I pay an exorbitant amount of
money that I meet with on Friday
mornings and we meet for hours you know
we talk about the craziest scientific
theological rabbit holy social
psychology stuff in the world cuz I have
to have that and when I worked at a
university I was every lunch was like
some Theory some some legal scholar
talking about talking about this with an
anthropologist I mean that was my whole
life for 20 years and I missed
that but your wife is right every
conversation like that feels like she's
not enough for
you and you get frustrated and she feels
her lack of making you
frustrated and so you have to be a up
and say okay I need
this but this isn't the person for that
when I was taken when I was taking when
I was at an MMA gym I needed like that
physical contact well that's not my wife
right she's not going to sit in the
living room and fight me so I had to go
somewhere
else see what I'm
saying yeah I get it I want you to
listen to your language I've been
pushing my family up a
hill my guess is your wife's tired of
getting
pushed yes you have like I get you feel
like you have to parent her I also often
not all the time sometimes people are
just immature I don't give a crap they
sleep in through their alarms they're
lazy they just don't
care there's also people who have just
flat given up because they can never do
it right whenever they try to do it the
way you want to do it it just goes
sideways or you change the rules or you
get mad or you're doing this or what
about
that is that ringing a bell yeah yeah
that sounds more along the lines for
sure
so do you want to end your marriage and
I don't I don't have a stake in the my
marriage is fine I don't have I don't
have a a stake in this I'm just asking
you point blank are you done with this
marriage I don't want to be no I want to
that's not the question I
ask I don't want to have eaten a bagel
for breakfast this morning I ate a bagel
this morning I never do that and I know
it's going to cost me my blood sugar is
going to fall off a cliff here in about
45 minutes I'm asking
you is your marriage over I want to keep
working on it I want to keep working on
it yeah but you also don't want to smash
chairs tell me am I going to work on
this or am I not going to work on
this no I'm going to keep working on it
okay the path forward I see for you is
and you're not going to like this I feel
like I've said this three or four times
the last uh several shows and I haven't
I don't think I've ever said this before
up until
now is that you find somebody to watch
your
kids and you blow off your 5: amm
workout for the next
morning and one night you take your wife
out to dinner
early and you hold both of her hands
across the table or you send your kids
to a babysitter somewhere else's house
and you do it at your house and you take
a knee in front of her and you just say
hey I'm
sorry I've been pushing you up a hill
I've been trying to create this thing in
my head and you and I could go down a
rabbit hole my guess is you're running
from something I don't know what you're
trying to hold together so
firmly or what picture you're trying to
solve for but your attempt to make
everything perfect in your home is
destroying your
home yeah you could probably make a care
out of me a lot going on well it's it
here's the thing you're doing it right
and what I mean by that is my guess is
you went through hell growing up and you
have found a way to solve for that and
that is systems and control and strength
and and and discipline and determination
Fair yeah cool that works on a David
goggin's podcast it does it works in his
real
life doesn't work in
99.9999999% of
marriages
okay yeah so if you want to stay married
you want to keep your family
together tell your wife I'm sorry I
acted like a child when I scream at you
I act like a child when I smash things
that will never ever happen
again I've been trying to force a life
on you I never asked you what you wanted
in this life what you felt like here's
exercise I want you all to explore how
do you want your home to feel when you
walk home from walk in from work every
day how does your wife want the house to
feel when she opens her eyes up in the
morning because my guess is that alarm
goes off in her body says don't get
up don't get
up how do you want do you want your kids
to heard you say that before and just to
like after that fight I did leave for
the for a night I went to a friend's
house and stayed there and when I came
back like I told her there was just this
feeling like it was like a two-hour
drive and an hour there I just had this
feeling like a backpack a heavy backpack
was just taken off is that was a day
that was the night I told her or the day
I told her I want a divorce and like I
don't think I really meant that at the
time but it was I just didn't know what
else to say to stop the the fight we
were having the conversation we were
having and so I left for a friend's
house and I just felt this relief that I
haven't felt in a long
time and what do you know about
feelings uh what do you mean by
that feelings are designed to keep you
safe they don't tell the
truth
yeah there's probably a sense of relief
that you didn't smash somebody this time
cuz that day is coming my
friend when you're going to be leaning
over somebody you love because you think
it's bad now your kids haven't started
really coming after you when they get in
first second third fourth Middle
School my fear is on your trajectory
you're standing over somebody you love
and they're curled up in a fetal
position with their face busted
up because that's where you're
headed yeah that's what I went through
as a kid and I don't want to exactly
that so I need you to hear me say with
all certainty 100%
certainty the thing you are trying to
achieve through radical discipline
through everybody doing everything right
through turning your family into a
military
unit is actually starving your body from
what your body needs because if you got
the crap eat out of you as a kid your
body still w wondering as a 5-year-old
why are you hitting me I'm a
kid and that's that ferocious rage that
comes out when you find yourself
smashing a chair after a pretty good
night with your family that's the fifth
that's the 5-year-old that's the fifth
grader still trying to defend
you the difference is your wife's not
throwing punches like your old man
did
and until you decide and this dude this
word sucks I hate it I hate it with all
my heart and it's the truth until you
decide to open yourself up to actually
let this woman hurt
you that's the only way she can actually
connect with you that's the only way you
can save your marriage it's called
vulnerability and that's beyond writing
little notes her writing little notes is
proxy that's her begging will you just
think of me one time over your stupid
Calendar please over your workout
program
please that's what she's
asking yeah do I even enter your mind
until you get home or am I just an
employee of yours that you think about
when you walk in and you're looking to
inspect my
performance and does this mean she's
perfect God no no
way but she's not on the
phone the things I can do you know
what you need to do is tell your wife
you're sorry and I would list very
specifically how you've hurt her and
it's not and you made me she's not made
you do one damn thing dude she's never
made you smash a chair you did that
she's never once made you raise your
voice you chose that and until you take
full ownership of
that it's going to be this tit fortat
thing now you're bigger and louder than
she is you probably have made made her
parent a certain
way you've probably made her clean a
certain way now she could always leave
but that's
different so I'd be very specific and
then I would let her know I have signed
up I'm going to see a counselor in my
community to deal with my childhood
abuse the time of running and flexing is
over I'm going to deal with
it that's the only way you can save your
marriage my friend that's it that's it I
wish there was another way that's
it and I think that relief you
felt was this a an illusion that ah the
responsibilities are gone that's very
very
temporary but I also think that relief
was your body saying oh thank God
because we were holding back from doing
something really
bad and I'm telling you right now you
need to go seek professional help to
deal with that inner rage age and for
especially men and women yes but
especially little boys who are
physically
abused from some tough guy
dad or that tough guy mom for that for
that instance that shame will haunt you
and your family forever until you say
I'm
done and I'm done isn't just fluxing
through every hard conversation and
trying not to hit a hole through the
sheetrock I'm done is sitting with a
counselor and saying I'm letting this
crap go I'm not letting that abuse run
my life
anymore I love you man call me anytime
and I'll be honest with you I'll shoot
it to you
straight I actually think your marriage
can be saved and not only saved I think
it can grow into something pretty
amazing the thing that your body has
been desperately screaming and searching
and running for all these
years but you're going to have to start
over from Square Zero from from from
Step Zero and your wife's can have to be
Allin too that means both of you are
going to have to be very vulnerable and
that's going to be scary for a
while